[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUZANNE FREY: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Suzanne Frey.
I'm responsible for protecting
the data our users entrust
to Google, and
specifically, to G Suite.
Now, our users include large,
heavily regulated enterprise
customers, say, in
financial services,
small businesses
that could become
the next big thing,
large national government
agencies, small local agencies,
education, institutions,
nonprofits, and the like,
across multiple jurisdictions,
regulatory requirements, and
locales all over the world.
Now, those users have
trusted their most sensitive
information to us.
It's a responsibility
that myself
and the thousands of other
individuals in Google Cloud
take very seriously.
I'm going to show
a lot of words,
I'm going to share a lot
of things we do today,
but frankly, at
the end of the day,
it's our actions that matter.
And every single day,
I'm proud to work
alongside these
thousands of Googlers who
take the security and the trust
our users have entrusted to us
very, very seriously.
So let's talk about
that concept of trust.
Why do we trust?
Actually, most
people don't think
about their fundamental internal
trust algorithm very much.
It's only when we're
faced with something new
that that actually
percolates to the surface.
Fundamentally, our
trust algorithms
are formed from the
moment we're born.
We experience something new.
We're vulnerable to something we
don't know, whether it's food,
you know, or an
experience or a location.
And we either have a positive,
negative, or neutral experience
with each one of
those endeavors.
And over time, we
learn to understand
what we're going to trust.
And we tend to
trust the things we
know because we've collected
data on them as human beings,
right?
And we trust what
we know until what
we know we can no longer trust.
So let's sort of back up
and think about the concept
of on-premise solutions.
And on premise, you're
not really vulnerable
or perceived not to be
vulnerable because you're
perceived to be in control.
I think many people
have heard the analogy
that on-premise solutions
are like sticking
your money under the mattress.
You're in control.
You know where
you put the money,
you know how much
money there is,
and if you need to go get
it, you know where to go.
Now, trust here
is because you've
gotten used to that, right?
You've become accustomed to it.
Nothing bad has happened,
and therefore, you're
comfortable with it.
And I was thinking
a little bit today
during the keynote
where customers
were talking about going
through the change management
process of moving to cloud,
and how easy that was.
Fundamentally, change
management, at its core,
is trust management.
It's actually getting
customers across that hoop
of going through
a new experience
and landing in a
positive and happy space.
That's something I think
that differentiates
Google very, very well.
That we are able to take
customers on that journey
expeditiously,
safely, and at scale.
Because any of you who
have taken an organization
through a massive change
management exercise
know that's not easy.
And fundamentally,
that's about trust.
Now, I said under
the circumstance,
you know, put the money under
the mattress, know where it is,
and you tend to believe that
that's the right way to operate
until it no longer is, right?
Because fundamentally,
many companies
today are realizing that scaling
to meet the demands of security
on an on-premise solution
is becoming an exceptionally
challenging game.
And if adversaries
happen to know
you are running your
operations on premise,
it is extremely easy for them
to break those operations.
So changes like movement to the
cloud-- they're not new, right?
Over time, customers went
from storing their money
under the mattress
to actually putting--
or I would say, individuals--
to actually putting
their money in a bank, right?
Something as important as
one's financial assets--
actually transferring that
trust to someone else to manage.
That happened over time,
banks made improvements,
and now many people
would say you're
absolutely silly to put your
money under the mattress.
Same thing with airlines.
Many, many companies didn't
want to use airlines,
or they ran their own until
they realized that the safety
and security is best
entrusted to someone who
does that as their business.
Electricity-- do you even
think twice about the fact
that your electricity
is probably
provided by a third party?
Kudos to all of you that are
doing solar and going green.
But for the most
part, if your company
didn't have electricity,
you wouldn't be running.
Yet people don't think about
that from a trust perspective
very much anymore until
there's a power outage.
And then, obviously, we
all think about it a lot.
These are not new trends.
This is where we are
with the cloud today.
We're at that precipice of sort
of going from the early adopter
phase to the late
adopters realizing
that those who do
cloud do security,
do fundamentally a full stack
of operations around security
and privacy, better than
individual on-premise operators
can possibly do today.
So I don't know
if somebody wants
to shout out our number here--
intimate setting.
What percentage of
companies do you
think have migrated some
portion of their operations
to the cloud?
I heard 80%.
96%.
It's actually 44%.
That's just some portion
of their operations.
That number's gone
up dramatically year
on year in the last three years.
How many companies have
migrated all of their operations
to the cloud?
I heard 1%.
5%.
The number is 8%.
Around 8%.
There's a huge upside
in that number.
And again, we're
seeing this number
grow very quickly, as well.
The cloud really matters, so
this was an interesting stat
I was presenting to some
CSOs a few weeks ago,
and was talking about, sort
of, presentations to the board
in the cloud and the like.
And you know, what are
some compelling things
that are happening?
So 20 years ago,
the average time
a company would spend on
the S&P 500 was 14 years.
Fast forward to the last five
years and the moving average,
and it's seven years.
Average time that a company will
actually spend in the S&P 500.
S&P 500 is a mixture of
public and private companies,
based on valuation.
Now, what's making
the difference there?
Well, there's a few things.
Highlighted most
dramatically here
are breakthroughs
in cloud computing,
and companies' adoption
of cloud computing.
It allows companies to
focus on what they do best.
So I'm going to name a few
companies here, all of whom
are great companies, but I
want to talk about valuation.
Airbnb as of Q2 2016 was
valued higher than Marriott.
Uber was valued
higher than Fedex.
All great companies, but
the higher-valued companies
were actually
cloud-based companies.
They were born in the
cloud, operate their tech
in the cloud, and
they're able to move
more quickly as a
result. They inherit
the massive, massive, sort
of, security and innovation
benefits of being in
the cloud as opposed
to those who have to
work through a lot
of different parties
to get done what they
need to get done on premise.
And even adoption of tech.
So look at some key
cloud providers here.
You know, it's gotten much,
much more accelerated.
Box was 39 months, actually,
to reach $10 million
in subscription.
Fast forward to Slack
in 2014, and we're
looking at 12-ish months--
a little less than 12 months
to the first $10 million.
And these curves keep repeating
themselves with new companies.
It's pretty awesome.
So in short, more
and more companies
are trusting the cloud,
and they are seeing
the benefits of the cloud.
Now, I'm talking right now about
valuation and things like that,
but I want to get into the
nitty gritty details of what
differentiates Google's cloud
and G Suite in protecting
your data.
We're particularly
proud of this quote.
Last year at RSA--
and I think a number
of folks, maybe, in this room
went to RSA this year, as well.
But the statement-- and
I've got to read it--
"CSOs would be wise to follow
Google's security operations
and strategies because the
company's infrastructure
is years ahead of
most enterprises."
Particularly proud
of that quote.
I happen to agree, and
I'm going to tell you
now a little bit more
about why this is the case.
So why our cloud is
the trusted choice.
Three messages I want
folks to take home today.
First is defense-in-depth.
And I'm going to talk
about the problem
of the
vendor-in-the-middle, VITM,
and what we did early on at
Google's birth to address
the security challenges
of having multiple vendors
in the mix.
Secondly, I'm
going to talk about
our security-first culture.
And all things breed
from that culture--
our innovations, the people
who protect what we do,
and the technology,
even the community
that we engage outside of Google
has its roots in our culture.
And last but not least is
our strong track record.
I'm going to talk about
how we prove that track
record and engage,
again, our users
and retain them from the
moment that they join us.
So let's talk about
the defense-in-depth
and the vendor-in-the-middle
problem.
When I first joined
Google, I actually
ran enterprise
operations on site.
I was an on-premise person.
This was a little
over 10 years ago.
And I worked on
technical infrastructure.
And I was like,
this crazy company
is building its own servers.
Like wow.
I mean, why are
you doing that when
you can just go outsource
and buy, and just buy in bulk
and get a great deal?
Wasn't too long until I
realized this is genius.
And we were the only company
doing this at the time.
And fundamentally, once
we start at the bottom
of that stack, our
technical infrastructure,
everything in that stack builds
up all the way through a G
Suite to provide a full
stack of security ownership
that is unrivaled
in the industry.
So let's start
with data centers.
We design, build,
operate our data centers.
And a lot of the stuff that's
in the news folks know.
We run highly efficient data
centers, highly green data
centers.
But we've also designed
for security from day one.
So access to the data center
floor, actual physical access
to the site--
they've all been part
of what we've done.
And the fact that
we own and operate
and Googlers own and
operate these sites
is fundamental to making sure
that from the very start,
anything that gets stored in
there is going to be protected.
We announced last
year we started
to design our own chips--
another moment where some
people said, you're crazy.
But from a security standpoint
and owning everything
from the ground up,
it's a very smart move.
Design our own servers--
heck, we design our own racks.
We design and build our own
racks, networking equipment,
and the like.
Again, we're eliminating
the vendors in the middle.
If you think about
on-premise, the number
of vendors managed
on premise typically
is a very high number.
You have no way of
understanding the collision
between those vendors, no way
of understanding and managing
and even controlling when's the
patch coming for this problem?
When are you going to fix that?
You often maybe even have a
strategic outsourcing vendor
managing those vendors.
Here, it's Google
and our customer,
and we are accountable
for making sure
that everything in
that stack is secure,
and we are empowered to fix it.
And that empowerment to fix it
differentiates us very strongly
from many other providers.
Furthermore, Diane
mentioned this morning
that we were probably, possibly,
the largest network provider
in the world.
And I'll get into
some stats on this,
so I'll do that
in just a second.
But that network capacity
allows us to route,
to prevent denial
of service attacks,
and to allow our customers
to scale very quickly.
So you have the security of
knowing the capacity is going
to be there when you need it.
We write our own
application services.
We write our firmware.
We write the services that
handle storage and job
scheduling.
We write our own code control
system and release management
systems, and I'll talk about
those in a moment, as well.
We don't use those
third party systems
because, again, it
would disempower us
from owning the quick and
expeditious resolution
of any issue that occurs.
And lastly, we build
our own devices.
This isn't to say you
can't use your own devices.
We're actually being very,
very open about the ecosystem.
But something like a Chromebook
is a clear differentiator
in our solution offering.
It brings the
power of Chrome, it
brings the power cloud,
and it [INAUDIBLE]
the fact that Google is
responsible for ensuring
you are secure, happy, and
delighted with your experience
with us.
I mentioned on
the server front--
I just want to talk
about a few things.
Again, servers are optimized
for a global fleet operation.
We don't put any sort
of unnecessary hardware,
even, on those.
And folks can go
into depth and look
online at what we do there.
Verified boot.
Again, a server will
not boot unless it
goes through extensive
amount of tests.
Hardened operating system and,
again, secured applications,
job scheduling and the like--
all of these things go
through rigorous checks
before they can even run in
the production environment.
And for example, I'll
tell you with, like,
even retirement of solutions.
Disk erase at scale.
We're going to bring down our
end-of-life a given server--
the process by which
we check, double-check,
triple-check a disk has been
erased before we crush it.
It's a pretty, pretty robust
and extensive operation.
We recognize that the importance
of protecting our customer's
privacy is paramount.
77 points of presence,
33 countries,
and a robust undersea network.
We were the first
provider, actually,
to engage in partnerships
in undersea network cables.
We've now set a trend
for the industry.
We're bring the internet to the
world in places of the world,
and connecting undersea
cables where there has
been no capacity previously.
Again, having a key stake
in those undersea cables
gives us the ability to route,
reroute, and bring the internet
all over, to any user.
And for a multinational company,
this is extremely important,
as well.
So now I'm going
to talk a bit about
our security-first culture.
There's a lot in here.
And here, you're going to
get more of the laundry
list of features that are
in G Suite and beyond,
and a little bit more about
the people behind this.
So security-first.
I mentioned that there
are thousands of engineers
in Google Cloud, and
all of those individuals
go through training
around how to handle
user data and the like.
But out of those
thousands, we have 700 plus
dedicated security
engineers that
are protecting our customer's
information at scale, right?
Coming up with the latest
and greatest innovations,
understanding how
adversaries are behaving,
building scaled and
automated processes
to protect and detect.
To detect and protect.
We've published over 160
security research papers.
Last month, for
example, some folks
may have read about breaking
the hash, the SHA-1 hash.
And, you know, that's
something that we're
particularly proud of.
We also know that SHA-1's
not used extensively,
but it's not safe, right?
And just by even
bringing that information
to the world, maybe
that scale, showing
what it took to break it--
it's an interesting paper.
I encourage folks to read it.
But it's one out of
many, many research
papers we've published.
And we engage with the
academic community,
and funded a lot of research
grants in security, as well.
I'll highlight, too, our
vulnerability rewards program.
We encourage folks
to break our system.
We encourage Googlers
to do it, and we
encourage anyone in the
outside world to do so.
And we motivate them with money
and fame, and some of them
even get jobs at Google.
And it's been a wonderful,
wonderful program
of mutual benefit for
us, because if someone
does find a problem,
that's great
because we are able
to patch it and bring
that benefit to our customers.
And again, we've paid out
several million dollars
in vulnerability
rewards to date,
and continue to keep that going.
We have global site
reliability experts,
global incident management
protecting our sites and data.
And if anything occurs,
again, the turnaround in SLAs
and incident management at
Google are unparalleled.
And I mentioned that we manage
and write our own source code
and release management systems.
We push 45,000 changes into
production every single day.
Did you notice?
To be able to scale that many
changes takes a special system
to be able to manage over
2 billion lines of code
and to do so with low
to no disruptions.
I challenge any on-premise
operation to meet that,
and to be able to turn things
around as quickly as we do.
Deep data security.
Another thing that
separates Google
from the rest of the pack
is how we lay data down.
First, we blow it up.
Blow it up into tiny shards.
We take each of those chance
of data and give them a key--
a chunk key.
Lay it down on disk.
In addition, we
take each of those
and we wrap them
in a wrapping key,
and that's hosted by our KMS.
That wrapping key never
leaves the KMS unencrypted.
Now, after we've done that,
as if that's not hard enough
to really be able
to figure out OK,
if I need to reassemble this,
how do I go about doing that?
We rotate those keys
every 90 days, as well.
So both sets of
keys get rotated.
So you can imagine a
gigantic paper shredder,
each one of those shreds
of paper having a key,
and then there being a
separate key that manages
all that information, as well.
Very, very hard
to reassemble data
unless you have all
of the information
and it's all verified, also
with an additional identity
layer every time someone
sources information.
In addition, we're
the proud developers
of Chrome, world's
most beloved browser.
And it is the only browser
that can be managed entirely
from the cloud.
That gives admins in
the enterprise space
tremendous power, and it
gives you a tremendous insight
into what's happening.
It also allows for wonderful,
wonderful interplay
and separation of
your work persona
and your personal personas.
And to be able to move
back and forth between them
is something we
do within Google.
We've worked with
a lot of customers
to show them how
that can be done,
and it's just a
phenomenal browser.
And I'm not just the
only one saying that.
I hear that often
from our customers.
Moving on to a
topic that we often
find since we're the
providers of Gmail--
the topic of spam, phishing,
malware, and the like.
So we get about 0.1% of spam
in the average Gmail inbox.
That's a very, very,
very low number,
and we're always working
to make that even lower.
And along false positives rates,
we get 0.05% of wanted mail
actually ending up
in the spam folder.
I know I may sound
biased, but I can't
think of the last
time I actually
had a valid message show
up in my spam folder.
Now, how do we do this?
There is a session later today
on email, Gmail security,
and so folks want
greater details,
I encourage them to
attend that session.
But there are
basically three phases
in how we handle
the evaluation and
the machine-learned
evaluation of what's
come in to your mailbox.
Now, 90% of all spam is caught
at the, sort of, SMTP layer,
pre-acceptance.
But once we have it,
we have a robust set
of proprietary algorithms
informed by decades, almost,
of Gmail operations that do
things like reputation-scoring
and entity co-concurrence and
a whole bunch of other things.
These algorithms
are world-class.
In fact, I see routinely
these days startups,
sort of coming to sell to
on-premise operators, who
sell one tiny
piece of that logic
that we've had in Gmail
for many, many, many years.
And even after we've
delivered a message,
we'll do deep scanning
of attachments.
Within four minutes-- and we
have this in Trusted Tester
right now--
that deep scanning of
an attachment occurs.
So we can be sure that
if you're about to launch
something or open it
up, it's going to be OK.
And we also do a lot of
click time evaluation.
So if you decide to
click a URL quickly,
real-time we will
check whether or not
that URL is safe to launch.
And there's a whole bunch
of HTML sanitization
and a whole bunch of
other things that go on.
I encourage folks, if you're
running on-premise operations
and you're talking to vendors
about individual solutions
to help you with spam
and phishing and malware,
there's a lot of great
providers out there,
but be sure it's not redundant
with what we offer already.
Now, we have layers
of secure messaging.
Beyond, sort of, spam phishing
and malware detection,
we've done a lot to help
with, for example, encryption.
Gmail now supports
S/MIME, which we're
particularly happy to do under
a bring-your-own certificates
model.
We just stopped blocking
JavaScript attachments.
And we launched last year-- many
of you may know about the red
padlock--
a TLS indicator to show if,
at any point along the way,
your email was sent unencrypted.
That tiny padlock in the
course of three weeks
changed the state of
encryption on the internet.
And there's great
examples of the way
that Google innovates in a
noninvasive, helpful, friendly,
Googley manner that comes
back to our culture.
And just says listen, I'm going
to give you the information
and you can act
on it accordingly.
And it's funny how the
self-organizing world
of the internet said,
hey, now that everyone
can see that I'm not
encrypting, perhaps I should.
We also launched
DLP with a whole lot
of prepackaged features.
For example, you know,
credit card numbers,
license plate
numbers by country.
Algorithms based on
by-country things
that allow you to
get sort of get up
and running really quickly
with prepackaged rules
as well as custom rules, regular
expressions and the like.
Common images, even, are scanned
and analyzed through DLP.
Now, we offer DLP
in Gmail and Drive,
and the rules and
adoptions have been great.
We also are looking into
providing even more information
to customers about
the adoption of DLP,
what DLP's finding [INAUDIBLE].
And stay tuned for more
information in that space.
You can now export
Gmail logs to BigQuery.
This was a long-requested
feature from our customers.
Basically, we had the logs.
Our customers requested them.
It allows them to do a lot
more analysis on their own,
retain them for whatever
period they wish.
We're obliged by our own
regulatory obligations
and the like to keep data
for certain amounts of time.
In this particular
case, customers
can tweak that or reflect
their own rules and regulations
and export the
information if they
wish, as well, to other tools
for analytics like Data Studio,
Tableau, et cetera.
OAuth.
So I've talked a lot about a
lot of these, sort of, what
I call first party features.
Let's see if I missed any that
maybe folks might want to know
a little bit more about.
I mean, you know, there's
OU-based sharing settings,
Drive IRM.
All of those things I'm happy
to discuss in greater depth
if folks want.
But in addition, we now have
available in Trusted Tester
the ability to limit your OAuth
scopes and whitelist apps.
This is another feature
that not only have
our customers requested, but
we drink our own Kool-Aid
at Google.
We use all of our
applications, and, in fact,
google.com is one of
the biggest customers.
So we have requested
this, as well,
and it's a really
important feature--
one that we're proud to
bring to Trusted Tester.
And I encourage you to talk
to your account manager
if it's something that
you're interested in,
or come to the meet the
product manager session.
Third floor of Moscone, I
think, from 4:00 to 6:00.
Everyone's invited to come
talk to product managers.
Mobile device
management, so MDM.
This is something that folks
have been asking for, as well,
for quite some time.
It's evolved tremendously
in the last few years.
And the ability to go mobile
is fundamental to any operation
anymore, and if you're managing
on-premise, mobile devices,
tablets, home device, bring
your own device, all of that,
it becomes complicated quickly.
We all know that
employee happiness
is rooted in the ability
to, sort of, hey,
I'd like to use my own phone.
I'm an iPhone user,
I'm an Android user.
People don't like to be forced
into certain technologies.
MDM actually helps you manage
a wide variety of devices
and ensure that your company's
policies are enforced no matter
what device they bring.
Again, something
we use at Google,
and we allow our employees
to use various devices
provided that the policies
are enforced on the device.
So also, it brings third
party app management,
more insight into your identity
and use, and the ability
to remote wipe.
I lost my phone.
Oh no, right?
Now, what are you going to
do when you lose your phone,
especially if it has a
lot of sensitive corporate
information?
Yeah, the phone may be
encrypted and the like,
but does somebody
actually have access
to your password,
your passcode, or any
of those things on that device?
At times, unfortunately,
you do have
to wipe that device remotely.
The ability to do that
easily with our solution
is, again, something that
differentiates our solution
from the rest of the pack.
We're talking about devices.
New sign-in from
Chrome on Mac here.
So on a MacBook, you
get a notification
for the first time you're
logging into a new device.
But not limited to
just Chrome on Mac.
You can get that notification
on your mobile, and vice versa.
You can also get new mobile
notifications, right?
Your account spans
all of these devices.
We do the work to
let people know
what devices are being
used and what's happening
to your identity in the cloud.
And you can go into more
detail and understand, OK,
was this me?
And if not, I'm going
to give you the chance
to secure your account.
Log yourself out of everywhere,
reset your password,
and get moving from there.
Very simple, very, very easy.
It's what we're
dedicated to at Google.
We're dedicated to
taking the complexity out
of the things that make
on-premise operations so hard.
So with that, I want
to talk about one
of the innovations that
broadly separates Google
from the rest of
the pack, and I'd
like to invite Reena
Nadkarni up to the stage.
Reena's a great colleague,
senior product manager,
who's going to take us through
a demo of security keys.
REENA NADKARNI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Reena Nadkarni, product
manager on the G Suite team.
Today I'm going to tell you
about security keys, both
from the end user side as
well as from the admin side.
If you can switch to
my laptop, please.
So let's start with a
very simple guest browser,
and we're going to look to
see what the experience looks
like if you need to register
for a new security key.
So I'm just going to logging
in with my test account user.
It's asking me for a password.
And what you're seeing
here is that the admin
has required this domain
to have a security key.
And we'll talk a little bit
about the admin features
that we are providing shortly.
But here, it's asking
me, hey, do you want
to register a security key?
Let's say I'm going to say yes.
And obviously, for
security purposes,
it needs my passport again.
And so now it's saying, do
you have your security key
with you?
And I have my
security key, which
was given to me by my admin.
You know, at Google, we
have them at our tech store.
We say you should literally
have these in a candy
bowl in every break room.
So I say yes, I have my
security key with me.
I click Next.
And it's telling me
to just plug it in.
And then when the
security key blinks,
I just have to tap
on it, and there--
this security key is registered.
This has associated my
account, my Gmail account,
with the security
key one-one-one.
And when I click Done
here, it tells me
that a security
key was registered.
It talks about when
it was registered.
And if I now go back
to my mail, it's
also going on notify me, saying,
hey two-step verification was
turned on for your account.
So if you look at
what this does,
this goes back to the
fundamental product principles
we have at Google.
We want security to
just work for you.
We want it to not
get in the way,
because once it gets in the
way, people don't use it.
So that was kind of the
end user side of things,
and how easy it is
to use security keys.
On the admin side, we've
added four new features
for security keys--
enforce, enroll,
recover, and report.
So if you think about enforce,
this is what you saw--
the notification when I
first came in here saying,
hey, you need to
register a security key.
This is because through the
admin console, the admin said,
you have up to a week.
It's a configurable
threshold of time.
And so that is enforce.
Enroll is that
self-enrolling process
that we just went through.
And then you have recover.
So many times, users sometimes
may lose their security key
or it gets lost or stolen.
Now, admins can do this at scale
where they can just, you know,
revoke that security key and
the user can register a new one.
And finally, to be able to
monitor the usage of security
keys, and make sure
that they're sending out
appropriate communications
to their entire domain,
you can report on the usage
of these security keys
using our admin console.
So in short, security
keys are great.
They're simple,
they're easy to use,
and they protect
you from phishing.
At Google, we use
them every day,
and I encourage you to come
to some of our more detail
sessions tomorrow where we
will be giving away some
of the security keys, as well.
With that, I'm going
to call Suzanne back
on stage to continue the
conversation on trust.
Thank you.
SUZANNE FREY: Thank
you, Reena, very much.
Now, I mentioned that security
keys strongly differentiate us.
Google, along with the
FIDO Alliance and GitHub
all got together to
develop this security key.
What makes this different than
traditional second-factor auth,
or, like, say, one-time
tokens and the like
is that no code is
actually passed.
So there's no man in the
middle opportunity for this.
So someone gets your
corporate credentials.
They can't get the
corporate credentials
and then figure out
what the check sums,
what they're for in OTP,
or something like that.
They actually need
the security key
and your corporate
credentials to be
able to hack into your account.
We have had exceptional,
exceptional results
at Google with Googlers
using security keys.
If I were to tell our customers
one thing and one thing
only that they needed to do
to improve their security,
it is to adopt security keys
writ large within your company.
And again, this is something
now that we're very proud of.
Other companies
have come on board.
Facebook, Salesforce,
and others have
recognized that this is a
very, very strong security
technology.
And I do encourage folks
to come get one tomorrow.
OK, so we've talked about
two other domains, right?
We've talked about how
our security-first culture
influences features,
it influences
community engagement,
how we operate day in, day out.
We've talked about
vendor-in-the-middle
elimination by building our
own stack and defense-in-depth,
and I want to finish up with
our strong track record.
Google was born in the cloud.
From day one, we have optimized
for security and privacy
in the cloud.
Have we done everything
perfectly for everything
from the very start?
No, we haven't, but we
have made any mistakes
and learned from them
extremely quickly,
and it has made us
super strong today.
And we do this at scale.
And we have lots of outside
and independent parties
verify that what we do
is what we say we do.
And we're proud to have the
badging of, for example,
ISO 27000, 27017, and 27018.
We're among the first
to get these badges.
We're FedRAMP-certified
for G Suite.
Really important, really
onerous, and really,
really this is one of
our proudest moments
to achieve that certification.
Something that if you can
hit the FedRAMP obligations,
you can pretty much
hit everything.
And the reporting
obligations to make sure
that we're consistently
compliant are strict.
And I'm proud to see some of
our FedRAMP folks in the room,
and grateful to everything
that they've done.
And grateful for
everything they've done.
And, of course, we
share our SOC reports--
SOC 2, SOC 3.
We do our SOC 1.
External auditors
maintain all of this.
We work with our
customers to share
the results that we can share.
And the fact that, for
example, your data is not
used-- your enterprise
data is never
used for advertising purposes.
I want to repeat that.
Enterprise data is not used for
advertising purposes at Google.
It would violate the
covenants of our agreements
with our customers.
It would violate our culture.
It would violate everything that
we've committed to customers.
But we get audited against
that to ensure folks
know that, as well.
In addition, we have data
protection compliance
ingredients that we
commit to our customers.
In our terms of service
outline, how we treat your data,
we in addition have a
data processing amendment
that shows specifically
what we do with your data
once we have it.
What our obligations
are if you delete it,
how long we can take until
it's completely gone.
And last but not least,
and we're very proud--
and I see Mark
here in the room--
of achieving common opinion
MCC approval in the EU.
What does that mean?
That basically means
anyone in the EU
who wants to use G
Suite has the approval
of their DPA in that country.
You don't have to go through
extra hoops or one-off one,
and that's for
most EU countries.
It's a big, big, big
differentiator for us, as well.
So I talked about, I
think, a lot of the things
that some folks maybe know.
Maybe they knew some of them,
maybe didn't know all of.
But there's a lot of
hidden wisdom in the cloud,
and specifically
in Google's Cloud.
The fact that we were
born in the cloud,
and that we have a huge
user base, across consumer
all the way through
to enterprise.
We have a lot of people
watching our service.
Look at an on-premise operation,
and you have your company.
You might have the good citizens
who are out there saying, hey,
I see a bug.
Or I'm logging in and I'm
seeing something wrong.
What happens when that's
tens, hundreds of millions
plus individuals
using that service?
You get near
instantaneous information
in a solution like that
about security and privacy
vulnerabilities.
It's a huge advantage
of using the cloud.
In addition, I often
say that security comes
in multiple forms at the cloud.
There's the obvious, sort of,
cybersecurity side of things,
and having the best experts,
protecting this information,
and that is the
reason that they show
up for work every single day.
But then there's also, sort
of, technical obsolescence
or stagnation, right?
Security is commercial
security, as well.
And if your company is
actually constantly getting
bogged down and can't innovate
quickly enough because they're
waiting for the next patch of
x, or the servers to arrive,
or the vendor to actually
get the right people in place
to get the job done, that is
going to slow your company down
to a rate that no company in
this environment can afford.
So security comes in more
than one form in the cloud.
And it's certainly
one of those forms
is commercial agility,
the ability to innovate,
and the ability
to take advantage
of each and every
other customer's needs.
We get information inputs
from multiple sources
all over the world, all
over different verticals,
all over different customers.
Those all get baked
into a common codebase,
and they get launched
across the world,
and they get launched quickly.
And that's another key
reason that the cloud
is a wise, wise choice.
No on-premise operation
benefits from that kind
of scale of input and that
kind of scale of monitoring.
So in closing-- and we're going
to have some time for questions
here--
I just want to quickly
summarize again
the three points I'd like
everyone to walk home with.
On-premise operations tend not
to build their own servers,
build their own data centers,
build their own application
services, have
their own networks,
and that's probably fine for
someone small until it's not.
And there's a vulnerability
or a patch needed by one
of n number of vendors
that's actually
put your company at risk.
With Google, the
buck stops here.
We are accountable for the full
stack, and we have to fix it,
because chances are, it's
not just one customer
who's impacted, it's many.
Second, security-first culture.
It's not just our
security engineers.
It is every engineer, every
product manager in the cloud,
that is responsible
for your data security.
And everyone goes
through training.
Everyone understands
that if we don't do that,
everything else is not
even necessary because we
got the security wrong.
And we have strong
community engagement.
And last but not least,
look at our track record.
We've been protecting the
world's sensitive information,
whether under the banner
of enterprise or not,
for well over a decade now.
I'm proud to be
a part of Google.
I'm proud to have the trust
of the customers in this room.
We all hope to have the trust
of our prospects, as well.
I'm deeply humbled by the
opportunity to be a Googler
and to serve the world
in this capacity,
and to work around so many
great people who treat your data
with the utmost respect.
And with that, I'd like to
say thank you and invite
the room for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]